thousands joined the line for Jabs and
you in the queue 18 to 20 year olds
finally eligible for theirs I'm not
necessarily excited a little bit kind of
nervous I haven't had an injection for a
few years but I'm looking forward to
getting kind of all the Jabs and just
kind of getting being able to go away on
holiday or whether I can do with two
jobs in the future I think it's
like wanted to go out and doing things I
think it's good that we're now hoping
that'll make a difference getting all
the young people to get the vaccine but
so today feels like a big day yeah and I
think it is with the long queue and
everything that will be here a while but
it's fine it's worth it um yeah I was
shocked I thought it would take months
but yeah I'm quite glad because I'm
hoping to go university in September I
hope that I can get vaccinated before I
go anyone in England over 18 can now get
vaccinated it is a massive Milestone
pop-up campaigns like this are crucial
to just get more people vaccinated in
North East London we have over 50
centers doing vaccination as we speak
and this is one of them and look at the
look at the turnout it's fantastic
those who've had both Jabs could soon be
exempt from quarantine rules ministers
are considering scrapping the 10-day
isolation period if daily tests are
carried out
Jenny Sylvester had to isolate last year
now fully vaccinated she'd welcome the
change I had food delivered so I
couldn't go out to get food right the
only person I saw was my daughter I
couldn't see my parents so yeah pretty
isolated yeah pretty lonely her daughter
Savannah isn't so sure I think I'd still
want to do it because like I could still
pass on someone else even if I don't get
it so just out of respect for them I'd
still like isolate a trial's underway to
assess whether it could work as they
queue up for vaccination there is an
anticipation it'll soon allow greater
freedoms but first scientists will need
to be certain any changes to the rules
won't increase transmission
some already believe that won't happen
if we want to move ahead and not have
people losing you know time at work or
indeed an education for younger adults
and and potentially for teenagers look
ahead then we are going to have to adapt
our guidance to make it reasonable and
long spells of self-isolation are
damaging for lots and lots of reasons
and that's something I think we have to
work to avoid once we have many more
people vaccinated no changes yet but big
numbers vaccinated probably means big
decisions can be taken soon Laura
bundock Sky News at the London Stadium